bachelor nation lit up after Charlize
posted this shot standing next to a
poster of pilot Pete with the caption
quote turbulence I like I cannot wait to
ask her about that right here at the
festival meanwhile Peter had this to say
about it on New Year's Eve well I heard
she likes her Glenn's choice I'm a huge
fan and I hope you enjoy but now come
Monday night though it seems Peter only
has eyes for his Bachelorette ex Hanabi
I'm so confused
what are you doing here making decisions
for my heart that was unexpected for me
I did not know she was coming that first
night
just real emotions kind of come up and
it was all real so are you and Hannah
together right now could be healthy
pilot Pete did his absolute best to fly
away from my Hannah questions but before
I could get to the other 30 women I also
had to ask about the scar on his head
that he got during filming there's the
scar there's a battle scar how do you
think I think it looks settled but it
looks like it was really bad at what
point it was my forehead was literally
split open I'm not exaggerating like
that that wide so it was literally just
a glass to the head it was a golf cart
into glass in my forehead you just
tripped
I never trip I just sat into the golf
cart bang my head reacted smash the
glass my forehead and what a trajectory
scar or not the women loved him
I just want to lick him up and down
I'm gonna give you some rapid fires okay
how much do you cry a lot do you say I
love you to multiple women no oh so
maybe you keep some those feelings
hidden how much sex do you have okay
believe it or not I know no one thinks a
I'm very private with my intimate life
yeah yeah whatever you say windmill boy
but Peter did give a little away the
finale is going to be a doozy
never pictured it kind of going that way
never imagined it kind of feeling that
way or end even ending that way
[Music]